[Music]
hi everyone welcome my name is Mike
Helmick I'm a software engineer working
on server lists for Google cloud
platform
hi I'm steering Giannini a product
manager on the service team
welcome to run containers on GC p7s
infrastructure well you all know what we
are talking about yeah we are talking
about cloud run a product that we are
really excited to launch and that we
announced yesterday that allows you to
run containers on all sevales
infrastructure so first what is several
s this is how we define several s at
Google cloud the three characteristics
are that you do not manage the
infrastructure you have a managed
security and you only pay for usage if
you take those three characteristics you
can think that doesn't only apply to
compute to compute products and indeed
all of those products are if we apply
those characteristics by definition
severus for example if you install data
file store is an ideal server less data
base if you want a you know do cron job
well cloud scheduler is an ideal way to
not worry about where your crowns are
running in a fully managed environment
and more precisely we have three
separate products including cloud run so
we are introducing cloud run that allows
you to bring several s2 containers so
Mike you know why don't you show us how
easy it is to deploy continue to run
we've shown this demo several times in
several different sessions so he may
have seen it already or just how quick
it is to get a pre-built container up
and running in cloud run so here I am in
the cloud run UI on the cloud console so
we're going to hit create service we've
provided you an example container right
here so this is our official HelloWorld
container it will pre-populate the
service name based on the container name
you're free to change that if you like
it
we'll give you a drop-down for locations
I promise that list is gonna get longer
soon and then I'm gonna click allow'
unauthenticated in locations so by
default services and cloud run are
private we'll talk more about what that
actually means in a minute but I want to
put this container on the Internet
I'm go ahead and kick hit create it
flips over to the service display see
creating service so there's a couple
cycles to go through here it's gonna say
deploying your vision performing health
check so after we pull your container
and our system we actually start it up
it's already done we start it up make
sure that it can start we return an
error if it can't and then we give you a
URL so right there I have an HTTP URL I
can click over in that container is
serving in less than 10 seconds thank
you I switch back over to the slides
will tell you about well how this works
so you might wonder that's a great piece
of technology but why would I use cloud
run so let's go a bit more into the use
cases so we can split them into two main
categories always you can run you know
HTTP request driven workloads so some of
them you will be using them for public
facing services anything that is exposed
to the internet that is serving things
over the Internet first of all a website
or exposing an API endpoints back-end
for your mobile app or just a simple web
web hook for the phone you are receiving
a web hook from github or a chat bot for
example but you can also use clarin if
you are breaking out the monolith of
your application and are using private
micro services in that case those
services are not accessible by anybody
on the internet they are within your
service your application and all of
those micro services will be
indefinitely scalable so if one of them
is not in use it will just not be scaled
up and it will be scaled up when needed
you can do direct micro service to micro
service but also do a synchronous task
execution and here we've seen many of
our alpha testers using cloud using
cloud run to do data transfer me
image processing video processing
document processing as you might have
seen in some other sessions and all of
this you can do with a synchronous task
execution well the task is going to
trigger the declarant service so as one
of our alpha testers says what is great
about that one is that because it
accepts any stateless container it
allows you to use your own custom tool
chains both in terms of to chain to
manipulate containers to build them but
also your tool chains inside the
container
in that case Thomas from Airbus is using
cloud run to run is own custom binary in
a surveillance way to do some image
processing but the binary is not
something that you usually can put in a
service environment except that Nova
squadron because you can give any
stateless container you can actually
give any software to run on a separate
environment so in that in that session
we are going to deep dive into cloud run
and in particular into the fully managed
version of clown run so we are going to
go over the many characteristics of the
products or use that you have a very
good understanding of it alright let's
go so first
containers containers and civilus you
know two things that we don't really
think go well together that reminds me
peanut butter and jelly you know who
would have imagined that mixing peanut
butter and jelly would be so delicious
well it's the same like you mix the
several s principles with the
flexibility of containers and you get
something really powerful and this is
what cloud on does so containers let's
keep going a little bit first they will
allow you to use any programming
language you want you're not wasting
thing restricted anymore about which
language you can use because the cloud
provider decided to only support those
languages no this time you use your
custom
languages I mean we are going to do a
demo with Alex here which is not
something that you've probably seen a
lot on the severus environment I
personally run shell scripts on cloud
run along with your favorite language
you can bring any language package but
also any OS package so if you have a
package from Ubuntu you want to install
you can do so along with these you can
bring your own custom binaries as long
as they are a compiled for the right
system but that's that's really
something very powerful you don't even
need to go from source anymore if you
have a binary that does something put it
into the container and as we all know
containers have a very logical system
around them in particular there are very
logical system of base images some of
them maintained by the official language
maintainer and all of this is available
on docker hub for example and lastly we
have to acknowledge that containers have
become an industry standard an industry
standard to package software to
distribute software to test software and
even to deploy software it's it's in my
opinion much better than a zip file so
Mac is going to talk to you about the
what your container needs to meet to
work on cloud 1 thank you so we have
what we call the container runtime
contract the container runtime contract
that we use in cloud run and cloud run
on GK is the K native container runtime
contract so this is an open spec that we
published it defined just a few things
that you need to do inside your
container for us to be able to
automatically scale it so the first one
is that we're focused on stateless
workloads what this means to you is an
application developer is that you should
not rely on any given instance of your
application living for more than one
request now in practice on cloud won't
run we do reuse an instance of your
container and we'll send multiple
requests to it but we'll also scale them
up and down as needed right so we're not
a great use case for say running a
memcache inside of your container you
can't guarantee it's gonna stay there
right with that we require that you
listen on a port a specific port we pass
in an environment variable
called port in practice it's usually
8080 but you should be prepared for that
to change at any given time that's part
of the contract and we only support HTTP
1.0 currently 1.1 we don't support any
stream in our pcs there's some scaling
issues with persistent connections that
we have to talk about more adaptive
after the talk and then instances of
your container are only running when
handling a user requests so this is how
we're able to offer the scale that we do
on cloud run so between servicing user
requests we actually throttle your CPU
down to near zero so that you're not
being billed your container is actually
not running so with that I'm going to
show you some code I'm going to show you
a demo that I've built so switch over to
the demo machine I'll show that URL
several times so you can you can get the
source if you like
so sterian mentioned this earlier I've
written this demo entirely in elixir
elixir is a dynamic language that runs
on the Erlang VM I decided I'd throw
some random things at cloud run and see
how we do I also happen to really like
functional languages so what I've
written here is a chat bot it works with
Google Hangouts chat so if you have a G
sweet domain this is something you could
easily do as a nice chat interface and
of course you know we're using the power
of cloud run to generate memes because
why not
so create
all right step simple man command crate
it's gonna go create a meme this is
actually two different micro-services
running out on cloud run one to do the
chat bot interface one to generate the
images response fairly quickly but let's
say here that what I want to do is I
wanna this is right now a direct chat
with the chat bot let's say I want to
put this in rooms because of course
memes are more fun if we're sharing them
with other people so I want this to when
it responds with the meme to put the put
the author attribute this to the author
of the other person who wrote it so
let's switch over to cloud shell here so
I've got my environment all up and
running imma show you a couple things so
the first is the container contract that
I mentioned listening on a specific port
so this is pretty easy to do in most
most languages and frameworks for a lick
sir this happens to be how you specify
specify this in the cowboy config tell
it to be a pool it from the system
environment variable called port by
default this is typically hard-coded so
you might find depending on your
language of your framework it might
listen on you know 4000 by default forty
two hundred eighty eighty eight thousand
there's lots of different variants in
there so make sure you get the right one
the second thing is I'm gonna show the
docker file so there's there's loads and
loads of examples out in the internet
for for different doctor files what I've
done here is I've actually created a
six-stage docker build which I know
sounds scary I've done that to leverage
caching in the build system so if I
build this like from scratch it takes
about four minutes to build using google
cloud build but with the caching if I
just change one file I'm able to recycle
and get a new container within a minute
and then we can leave that deployed
fairly quickly on cloud run so here I'm
doing again nothing nothing funny I'm
pulling from the elixir 1.8 Alpine image
which is maintained by the elixir
community of course Alpine then being a
slimmed down image what this gives me
this gives me the entire build chain
that I need to build and release an
elixir application again there's a
couple different steps here with
different layers where I'm copying
specific files looking for hey if the
mixed build file has changed execute
this layer if it hasn't used the cash
flow and move on to the next thing it's
compiling all the static-x assets
compiling my application
and then what I'm doing is in the last
stage there I'm pulling a vanilla Alpine
3:9 image copying over just the binary
just the elixir or sorry the airline VM
my application and then a stipple start
command right so I actually have a very
small image this is less than 40
megabytes when pushed to GCR which means
that it deploys and starts up very
quickly and then the bot code itself for
those of you are interested and wanted
to dig in later I have a simple
configuration here this is a list of
tuples with strings to look for and
functions to dispatch to and then in the
bot here this is the code that we're
going to actually change so in the
create function let's see it should be
wearing create a meme right here
so in the in the message that I get
that's create template let's see great
meme in the message that I get from
hangouts chat has some additional
information about who sent the requests
so I'm just gonna pull the sender the
sender name from that JSON that I get in
and say created by sender name okay
simple code change just gonna open I
don't have mix installed here so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna actually send
this over to Google cloud build G cloud
build submit give it a tag for where I
want it to go you can use we support
tags on GCR so if you want to tag
something as v1 or switch to a v2 and
maybe switch between them we support
that at deploy time we resolve the
current value of that tag to the image
digest so that if we ever had to
redeploy that in the future which is a
feature that's coming soon we would pull
the exact same image and not not the new
one from the tag so I'm gonna go ahead
and hit submit on that like I said this
takes about a minute or so so we're
gonna switch back to the slides and
we're gonna talk rather than let you
watch the build output cuz it's not very
exciting thank you so let's recap what
happened here
we had source code and we packaged all
of this into a container image to do so
you know the DFA
to tool that everybody has heard of is
darker the darker command-line darker
build - key Dhaka push this is something
too that you can use to build container
images locally on your CI system
wherever you want as mike has used
google cloud also offers builds as a
service if you want where you only pay
for when the build is running and you
know when nothing happens it's all
managed for you so this is cloud build a
cloud deal you can do a darker build
this is what Mike has done but you can
do also do more complex - multistage
bills with with the cloud builder TMO if
you look at the documentation it's quite
powerful actually because cloud build at
the end can build containers but can do
much more like deploying or executing
actions so we can use cloud build for
continuous delivery - personally I
recommend to other tools to build
containers if you have a Java developers
I heard that jib is very very good so
jib will allow you to by importing a
maven or a maven package build a
container for your java app without even
having darker installed locally so then
you use it at one command and you have a
container from a maven package that you
installed into your own from that XML
also personally I'm a fan of build packs
so build packs will help you go from
source in a given language to a
container the recipe to transform your
sauce into a container is contained
inside the build pack and so at the end
you run one command which is a pack
build and you will you will end up with
with a container at the end without even
having to worry about writing a dock of
file and as I said you know you can
encourage you with containers to
leverage this continuous integration
systems and continuous delivery that
means that you build your container once
then you run your test on it then you
deploy it to staging then you deploy it
to production but it's always the same
container it's the one you've built once
and you test it that that goes into
production it's not some sauce that are
rebuilt every time so we are very sure
that it's really the right thing that
goes to prod and so for this as I said
cloud deal can be a very easy tool to do
so but of
Jenkins and many other tools are helping
you do that then once you have your
container image as we've seen we've seen
in the in the first demo you can deploy
it to cloud run so we can do it from
their user interface you can do it from
the command line Ziggler better run
deploy - image and so here you go from
your container image in Google Cloud
container registry - cloud run with one
command on Kuran you get an endpoint to
invoke it and all of this if you
remember the first demo happens very
fast just a few seconds I think once in
some cloud run yeah what's its own cloud
run we give you URL everything you
deploy will automatically get a stable
URL for that service under the run app
domain security with SSL if that doesn't
work for you we offer free custom domain
mapping so any domain you own you can
bring your base domain or a subdomain
off that base domain map it to an
individual cloud run service and with
that would give you a free SSL
certificate that we will Auto renew for
you right before it about a month before
it expires we could be a little bit of
leeway there free certificates from
let's encrypt we also offer firebase
hosting integration firebase hosting
allows you to add static content through
a CDN or you can do like cached API
request so if you are serving serving
something where the the answer to the
API doesn't change very frequently doing
a firebase hosting integration is
potentially a good solution for you in
that space alright so the container
built I checked
why we were Darren was talking so switch
back over to the demo we're gonna
actually go ahead and deploy this change
so you can see here that it took a
minute and 42 seconds which ice which is
less than half of the time for a
complete build so that's good I
encourage you to look at the caching
functionality of Google cloud build and
it gives me the output here so let's see
ok so I'm gonna go and I'm gonna cheat
I've got the command already there so
g-cloud betta run deploy the name of the
service - - image the name of the image
hit deploy so I'm gonna hit that why
that's going we talked about a couple of
other things you can do on the command
line
you can specify the memory for your
containers so the default memory is 256
megabytes for instance you can scale it
up to 2 gigabytes for instance depending
on what you need to do i've already
specified 512 for this container but i
don't need to specify it every time i
deploy we remember server-side what your
settings are same thing with environment
variables there's a couple of
environment variables that this
particular container uses and i
specified those the first time that I
deployed I don't need to specify them
again so we remember all of that
server-side ok so this is done I'll show
you where that's persisted real quick so
if I go back over to the cloud console
go into the chat bot service I can see
the list of all of the revisions that
I've pushed so we preserve the history
for you there and I can see here that a
couple of environment variables that
were set i see the concurrency i had
this little tab called Gemmell so we're
gonna talk a little bit about the API
I'll show an example in the slides later
give you a preview now you see at the
top they're serving a native dev v1
alpha one this is the K native serving
API completely represented for you in a
managed service okay so prove that this
work will go back over to the chat bot
will create that same meme again and
this time it should say who created it
there we go okay so we clearly got a
cold start there which happens when you
deploy a new one but interactively now
much faster okay so we I say in summary
there we built built a Medeco change we
built an image we deployed it the cloud
run that new version was up and running
I was in 10 to 15 seconds so I switch
back to the slides talk a little bit
more about some of the stuff that's
going on there at a high level I want
talk a little bit about the resource
model that we use I mentioned it's the
Kay native serving API the top-level
object and there is service so you
create a service request come in to a
service every time you change that
service you get a new revision so
revision one revision two so on and so
forth only one reversion is serving at a
time so if you if you dig into the hood
under the hood of the K native service
object there's a couple do we call modes
there's run latest mode which is
currently what cloud runs supports there
are also some other modes like release
mode that lets you do a traffic split
those things are coming soon win
requests come in to the current latest
revision we scale the number of
container instances of that revision
that are needed to handle the incoming
traffic and we scale that both up and
down and you're only billed when you're
actually handling a user request in the
K native resource model there's a couple
of other objects there's route and
configuration and also the revision
resource in particular we do expose all
of those K native objects in read-only
mode so you can really dig in and see
exactly what's going on with your
declarative config but we do require all
changes right now to go through the
service object I showed you a preview
for but again K native serving API if
you go to github.com /k native slash
serving you can see the entire K native
serving project all of the issues
designs we've written things like that
and then under the hood you have the
Yama file here so currently we do not
support coop cuttle we cannot take
requests through that same declarative
interface that support is also again
coming coming later this year by the
same interface so the same config you
can take from cloud run move it over to
cloud run on gke get the same container
up and running in that environment
cloud run is a regional service each
service lives in a different region you
can deploy the same service to multiple
regions if you like we do not currently
offer a global load balancing over those
regions and right now we're live in US
central one but we have a bunch more
regions that are gonna be coming online
very very soon it's not gonna be a long
way to promise cesareans we'll talk a
little bit about the invoker permissions
and private services yeah let's spend
some time on the very important concept
of cloud run so as Mike described
requests are coming in and they are
reaching your service or not because in
front of your service there is an
orthotic is a notification layer that
you use I am to control who has the
permission to invoke that service so for
example it can be anybody with all users
it can be a specific user or even a
specific service account so this feature
is key to doing public or private micro
services and let's see a few use cases
how you can use that feature you will
see it quite powerful so the easiest one
the most obvious one is you have a cloud
run service you want to expose it to the
Internet to anybody in that case there
is no Auto Tech ation required to invoke
your service how you achieve that is by
giving all users the right to invoke
your service all right this is a public
service
now if within your architecture you have
one micro service that calls another
micro service for example your front-end
now invokes your back-end well your
back-end dozen is not exposed to the
Internet right so to be sure that only
the front-end codes can call your
back-end and not anybody or not even
your development team on production well
this is how you can do it you can give
the invoke permission to the front-end
service account so then because each
cloud run service is associated with a
service account and so then when your
front-end calls your back-end it has to
do it by giving it by by you by sending
with the request a special header to
authorize the request once you do this
only the front-end can call the back
so all of this is leveraging I am
something you probably know already if
you are using word cloud but that's not
it if you want to do a synchronous event
processing I recommend you to use
pub/sub to create a topic and then your
subscription and then here what you do
is that you give to the subscription and
identity with the service account this
is the thing you see under the top and
then your service you only allow that
perp sub identity to invoke your service
so once again your service is completely
private and only pub/sub has the ability
to invoke it that's how you make a
synchronous processing super secure so
in that case I give the invoker role to
the pub sub service account and by the
way when you use pub serve and cloud on
the run dot app URLs are already
validated for you you don't need to do a
verification step of ownership of that
URL we already know it's yours this is
pepcid one of my other tool in my tool
belt is cloud tasks which as of maybe
yesterday is now supporting HTTP targets
so cloud task is a queue queuing
mechanism you can send task to a queue
and the queue will ensure that the tasks
are processed by pushing them to a cloud
service or to an app engine service and
in the case of a cloud service it's the
same you give the service you give the
cloud the service account of cloud task
the permission to invoke your service
it's like web server one other very
useful tool that you should all know
about that exists in DCP is cloud
scheduler class scheduler is the most
simplest tool you can think of it's cron
as a service and here it's the same you
do you just say I want to execute that
service once a day klutzy girl will take
care of that once a day it will send a
request to your cloud run service and
again you can leverage I am to ensure
that only cloud scheduler is able to
invoke your service and not exposing it
to the internet so same you give the
invoker role to the cloud stealer
service account
let's see a demo of hogs chlorin kale
actually scale yeah the sous-chef
machine why don't we do some show demo
of a service going from zero clients to
fifteen thousand concurrent clients over
the course of 60 seconds each of these
is hitting a hitting a worker job that I
wrote that simulates a real workload so
it burns some cpu it sleeps to simulate
Network IO burn some CPU again so then
hit run this particular worker is using
a concurrency setting of aiding and
eighty and when I get to the next slide
I'm gonna tell you exactly what that
means okay so our test is up and running
off to the races so the the linear line
that's going up is the number of clients
that are hitting this service the blue
line is the latency so I would expect
the latency to be a little bit variable
as we scale up the number of container
instances but then it should level out
as we get to sort of a steady state so
up to 6,000 clients they should be
sending about two QPS each so as we
cross 8,000 here 8,000 clients here that
means they're handling about 16,000 QPS
in 30 seconds after starting at zero so
we're zero this service was completely
idle across 10,000 so on the way up
again to 15,000 over the course of 60
seconds we've successfully handled over
half a million requests just crossed
600,000 successful requests there's a
couple of errors in there sometimes we
do see some errors when you send a whole
bunch of load really quickly and have to
scale up alright so we hit 15,000
requests our 15000 clients we
successfully handled over 800,000
requests again this scaled up from
nothing to a whole bunch of instances
very very quickly so let's switch back
to the slides thank you
I'm gonna talk a little bit this
objective slides please
talk a little bit about the concurrency
settings so we should show some stuff
with automatic scaling let's talk about
concurrency so in many service
applications today concurrency setting
is one Oracle single concurrency that
means that any instance is only going to
be handling one request at a time so AWS
lambda and Google Cloud functions both
use this single concurrency model what
that means is that you may have to start
up a whole bunch more instances you
might experience a lot more cold starts
in cloud run we let you have multi
concurrency into a single container
instance right so we go up to 80 you can
specify actually any number from one to
a thousand because that's what Kay
native allows you to specify but the
limit is 80 I'll be hoping with you here
and what this allows you is optimized
resource consumption so if you have a
service that makes lots of Network calls
there's no reason not to put multiple
requests into that container at once
right right and boy the cold start I
want you to optimize cost you're only
conveying for the the time that your
container is running all right so if
you're able to bin pack and get a lot of
the shared CPU in there you can actually
end up with a lower cost overall if you
have a CPU bound workload if you are you
know using that CPU at 100% for the
entire duration of the user requests
single concurrency probably actually
makes more sense for you so you there's
a lot of variability and what you
actually need and you can't set this to
any integer along the way so what I've
done is I I run a couple of load tests
in with different concurrency settings
here so you can see here with 400
clients sending three QPS or three
requests per second the number of
instances I needed on single concurrency
was just over 500 so it's but I was
about 540 or so and that was able to
scale up very quickly as you can see
here as the traffic drops off those
instances start to go away so again
you're only paying for when it's
actually handling requests run that same
test with the concurrency of 80 I picked
out about 150 instances right so I don't
know exactly what the cost was between
those two tests but I know this one was
cheaper there's less CPU time less
instances involved so this is truly a
pay for what you use experience
rapid scale-up rapid scale down hey
they're talking about how you can
actually like the bug and run these
things - it's important
Thanks so out of the box as you would
expect from any surveillance platform we
give you visibility into your services
by integrating with tag driver
monitoring you see all of your requests
logs application logs standard Alstom
dev logs into staggered or logging and
when you use takeover logging as you
might know your exceptions are going to
be automatically captured and grouped
into our groups in stock driver error
reporting all of this is out of the box
as soon as you start using cloud run we
are also a partner and partnering with
data who are supporting cloud run as a
monitoring solution so as you've seen in
Mike's demo quadrant scales scales up
and scales down it's very important to
know that each of your cloud services
will going we go will be automatically
scaled to as many container instances as
needed to handle the incoming requests
right the concurrency is on each of
those container instance but the
container instance can go very high like
you've seen in Mike's demo I think it
went up to 500 when you had concurrency
of one so but what does that mean for
your bills well what you pay is not the
number of scheduled instances what you
pay for is the exact CPU memory and
number of requests that you are actually
using and down to a granularity of a
hundred millisecond so what that means
is that you actually the auto scaling is
our problem you only pay when there is a
request coming to your services so let's
take an example this is let's look at
one of those instances we can have many
of them but let's look at one this
instance will consume CPU and memory but
when are we charging you for the CPU in
memory depends on if it is processing
requests or not so on on the x-axis it's
the time but let's see so our first
request arrives and is returned
another request arrives and is returned
this can happen because as you know
clarin has multiple concurrency so on
cloud functions it's only one request at
a time on a given instance but on cloud
run two requests can come at the same
time on a given instance when that
happens what we are charging you for is
the beginning of the first request up to
the end of the last request outside of
this you are charged 0 you don't pay for
this for anything outside the processing
of the request you only pay for CPU
memory that you use when your containers
are processing requests so from your
perspective it's literally scaled down
to 0 instantly from our perspective we
might keep some things warm in case more
requests arrive but really from the
perspective of your bill you stop paying
as soon as the requests are returned and
how can we achieve that magical scaling
and mike is a bit more there's lots of
magic I'm gonna talk about one piece
we're talking about G visor so G visor
is the container sandbox runtime that we
use on cloud run it's an open source
project run by Google G visor dev is
where you can get a lot more information
about that it provides a secure
container isolation boundary so we're
able to start these instances extremely
fast tear them down it's very cheap to
do so ok one thing about G visor not all
sis calls are implemented so you might
run into some unimplemented syscall
warnings which we put into your stack
driver logs so if you find that your
application is not working the way you
expect i would encourage you to go look
there a couple things about that
not all unimplemented syscalls are a
symptom that something is not working
correctly so I see like set saw cops is
one that is unimplemented for some of
the era T's of that function call and
usually that's a red herring it's not
actually a problem if you do find that
on ballistic all's are actually causing
a problem for application we encourage
you to contact support and we can work
with you to try to figure out exactly
what's going on there
yeah you you might hit some what we call
limits of the fully managed version of
cloud run for example today you cannot
pick more one more than one V CPU or
more than two gigabytes of rams you do
not have access to a GPU on clarin we do
not yet allow you to connect to cloud
sequel or to connect to your V PC but
that's coming very soon and so and as
Mike mentioned we do not yet integrate
with Google cloud load balancer but you
know what cloud run also we have another
version of Lauren which is cloud run on
gke so if you feel limited by those
restrictions well you can benefit from
the exact same cron run developer
experience auto scaling and automatic
endpoints but within your own GK cluster
that is called cloud run on GK and the
two have been designed to expose the
exact same API which is the connective
API it's super easy to switch between
one or the other if you can change your
mind later and really it has been
designed so that if you feel limited by
one you can go to the other in your own
cluster this time so next I would like
to invite on stage one of our alpha
testers who have been working with us
for months on cloud run on Tuan and
Sebastian from baolian thank you
everybody
before telling you more details about
the use case we have uncut on obviously
it's normal for me that I need to
introduce to you what is VI because it's
very important for you to understand how
the business of area is very into the
solution like that ok so we work for
failure
we are 170,000 people working in more
than 50 countries around the world we
have a French company but we are now
worldwide we have a different of shusuke
a different solution and on this
particular use case you will understand
what is very linked to the job we have
and what the jobs we have 3 different
job the first one is the water by what I
mean collecting water providing solution
for water and recycling water the
second one is the waste waste management
that means we will secure your waste for
millions of tons every year the last one
is the energy solution we provide an
energy solution for the industry for a
lot of cities around the world to be
just more precisely the cuts on the
slide is just for the fan we don't
recycle the cats don't don't be afraid
but before telling you more about the
use case we have it's very important for
me to introduce to you what the cloud
strategy that we have and we you will
understand that we have five principal
pillar on that the first one is no ups
when I say no ups I say when we have a
new use case when we are transforming an
existing application first of all we
every times think about using micro
services micro services mean using
solution like one and thank you steel
and thank you Mike
but why this is just because an
application is not fixed at the time
your application will evolve in the time
maybe tomorrow maybe next week maybe
next month and you need to be agile on
the developments
the second point very link it to the
first one is the server less and we love
App Engine we love cloud function and
now we love cron and that is very
important not only because of your money
because as Stephen say you only pay for
what you use but also because now you
know that viola is an environment or
company we need to take care of about
the Conscription of the material and the
solution we use we we only need to use a
solution when we need and as students
say on the very nice billing models you
are only charge of the solution you need
when the service is not running you
don't pay for anything so that means for
earlier we are not using server of
Google when we know we don't need that
okay that's the link between the
environmentally impact of urea and the
environment impact of Google of course
we don't want any data center because as
you probably know Google is doing that
very well we are not an IT company
that's not all jobs okay the first one
is Sexual by design you have seen a lot
of different layers of this solution
that promise you to be sick sure when
you develop an application and you push
the code on Calvin that's why we love
that and the last one is that's why we
are here we love using Google cloud and
just another one very small company with
tree later that I don't have to mention
special Thank You Antoine so I'm going
to present you our use case so in our
use case Veolia is managing watch our
treatment branch and arching a lot of
data and data can be sensitive or
subject to local regulation so we see
for them with a specific local algorithm
whether private key is the only store on
site then the data is ready to go on
cloud on Google cloud so on Google cloud
we have two layers of security the first
one is a native Google Cloud Security
layer and the second one is the
encryption on site on cloud we are going
to make a lot of processing to make some
prediction for the local site on during
the world process if someone tries to
read the data even the local IT team in
group managing the Google Cloud workload
we won't be able to read the data no
data nor the result because it's afraid
before the processing during the
processing and after the processing then
to that I send back to the local site
and the client can answer further data
with a private key and get the insight
of the data so how to do that to do that
we need first a specific kind of
algorithm called a morphic algorithm
this kind of algorithm are made from
several trees from tens to hundreds and
provided by the CI tech Institute which
is actually the Atomic Energy Commission
Research Technology Center in France so
this kind of algorithm first we have to
dispatch the tree calculation which our
first entry point in our cloud one
instance because actually the CI tech
Institute providers only binaries and
these binaries have been linked into a
docker image so when we publish the
message for each tree we are going to
trigger at the same time
also tree calculation and the result
will be stored in a cloud file store
database when all the trees have been
calculated who calculates a final step
which is called a median calculation to
have the final result of the prediction
and the result will be sent back to the
clients during the wall professor I said
before the data is he Fred completely so
to implement the use case Corwin bring
us a lot of benefits first one of course
as we have the courage with the binaries
we could plug as a service a G's docker
image without any effort
the automatic scaling because we have a
lot of trees to calculate sometimes
several androids and you can last a few
minutes so calculating them in the same
time it's really something required to
have the quick answer of the prediction
multi root support because we need to
dispatch the tree calculation and the
media calculation use the same docker
image so to have the multi root we have
only one deployment to maintain fast
deployment is also a mandatory feature
because when we want to make an upgrade
on the algorithm we need to deploy
quickly to answer the new new feature we
want to to improve and of course the
last end of the list we save money
because we only pay for what we use in
during the processing thank you I
brought back thanks to you for helping
us during this alpha and beta of Quran
your feedback was really variable during
that phase and that's why we we are very
proud to have you with us on stage today
okay so as super Sayan Antoine mentioned
a grill clad has a few other several s
compute options so I would like to spend
one minute helping knew how to pick one
option if you it's mostly it mostly
depends on the level of abstraction you
want to position yourself at if you want
to think in terms of very simple
function that are sourced based that can
be triggered via HTTP but also by event
triggers by binding your function to
some resources then cloud functions is
really the perfect fit for that
it's GA we announced many new languages
for cloud functions yesterday many new
features coming really severus functions
this is cloud functions for use cases
that are more web apps or web backends
then well you also want to think in
terms of source code and not have to
deal with the container then App Engine
will be the best fit to run your severus
applications so like cloud run and App
Engine scales up and down on demand and
takes your source code as input we
announced new languages for App Engine
standard environment recently and for
anything else
actually that you want to run on a
server less environment that that that
is able to take as an input an HTTP
request chlorin will be the best fit for
that it is supporting it is taking your
container images and inputs and can be
triggered by HTTP but also as
synchronously using perturb and cloud
tasks so clone run to recap containers
to production in seconds the benefit of
containers are multiple you can put any
language any binary and packages into a
container and deploy it's very fast so
as you see Severus is not only for
functions and
it takes a container and runs it in a
service way and yes Claude run is
natively surveillance as we demonstrated
to you it scales up and down you only
pay for the exact usage of your clutter
on instances and I haven't seen any
server to manage so there is no
infrastructure management which can run
and lastly we haven't put so much
emphasis on this but clarin gives you
one experience where you want it so what
we've talked today is mostly about the
fully managed version of cloud ram but
we also mentioned cloud run on gke which
gives you the same developer experience
but this time inside your GK cluster and
as Mike mention all of this actually
exposes the K native serving API so
thanks to that API and runtime contract
you can actually run cloud run workloads
anywhere on kubernetes where you can
install k native so that removes the
vendor lock-in that you might be wrong
with about so these are the three
pillars of cloud one bringing several s
ability to containers I would like to if
you want to learn more I have a few
sessions to recommend one of them is an
intro on what's new in 7s another one is
another view of both cloud run and claw
run on gke and another one is a deep
dive similar to this one except that a
deep dive on cloud 1 on gk if you wanna
ask those questions if you wanna try the
demo all of this is on github and we are
available on twitter and follow us on on
get up - and lastly I think Mike and I
really want to thank - thank you - for
attending this session we really want to
thank or alpha testers for providing
such large amount of feedback and
helping us shape cloud run for for it to
be ready today for you we really want to
thank our engineering teams who have put
so much effort into cloud run in Quran
on gke and really know your next step is
definitely get started give it a try
cloud or google.com slash run thank you
[Music]